sí
el poder de la palabra
a veces no sabemos cómo nuestras
palabras pueden influir tanto en los
demás como en nosotros mismos
hola mi nombre es robert cayó en camper
y hasta hace poco yo pensaba que no era
una persona inteligente año tras año me
creí la idea de que no lo era y que no
iba a poder lograr absolutamente nada
relevante en mi vida
qué van a decir de mí que van a pensar
soy capaz
ellos quedarán
ellos cambiaron al mundo
pero yo también quiero cambiar el mundo
quiero dejar mi marca en algún lugar y
como debe hacer eso si mis profesores ya
me dijeron que dedicarme a lo que quiero
no es relevante
tal vez no era la mejor algunas materias
pero en algunas otras sí y no lo notaban
incluso mis compañeros me lo decían
y no les culpo es lo que nos han
enseñado y yo lo permití
y pues ellos si van a cambiar al mundo
ni siquiera preguntaba lo afirmaba
les puse esas palabras y yo me puse
otras
me importaba tanto que ni siquiera
estudié la carrera que realmente quería
estudiar y no sé si ustedes sabían pero
el 80% de los estudiantes no saben qué
carrera elegir al terminar el colegio
y como no pues cuántas veces no
escuchamos a alguien decir es clínico
ataque que soy una carrera real
o también el papel de la mujer que aquí
estudian no sea una ingeniería esta no
es una carrera para mujeres y viceversa
esa no es una carrera para hombres en
algunas otras carreras
cuántas veces no escuchamos con más del
menos una carrera artística música
etiquetando las como en un género o si
es de inteligentes que ésta no es para
alguien que no es tan inteligente
incluso desprestigiando y comparando
universidades
a la hora de elegir una carrera el 40
por ciento de los jóvenes mexicanos se
equivocan
y esto es porque se ven más motivados
por el prestigio y la presión que dan
tanto los papás como los amigos haciendo
a un lado sus capacidades y deseos
pero siempre decimos que los jóvenes son
el futuro
queremos que lo sean no
son el presente ellos ya están naciendo
el futuro y cómo van a ser el presente
si ellos no lo saben
si seguimos utilizando estas palabras de
fracaso y de rechazo con ellos
pero es que definimos la inteligencia
como una forma de ser como si tuvieras
que tener una personalidad y un aspecto
físico adecuado para ese papel y por eso
dudamos de quiénes somos de las
habilidades que tenemos
y pues bueno para todo esto que es
inteligencia a lo largo de los años han
sido muchos los que han definido el
concepto de inteligencia algunos dicen
que es el resolver problemas otros que
razonar entender y pues realmente no hay
un acuerdo en cuanto a la definición de
inteligencia sin embargo el psicólogo
howard gardner ideó la teoría de la
inteligencia múltiple
la cual defiende que existen diferentes
tipos de inteligencia y que cada persona
puede desarrollar más uno u otro tipo
hay tantas y nos enfocamos en tan pocas
y en cosas absurdas que nos olvidamos de
las capacidades y de los sueños que
tenemos
aunque tengas un hermano gemelo y vivas
en la misma casa en la misma cama los
mismos papás la misma educación los
mismos amigos los dos van a tener tipos
de inteligencia diferentes
pues es que hay que entender que el
tiempo y el aprendizaje son relativos
que una persona tenga 35 años no quiere
decir que haya aprendido menos que una
de 50
todos tenemos experiencias de la vida
completamente distintas
y depende de absolutamente todo de la
familia de la escuela la educación los
amigos
y eso hace que tengamos capacidades y
habilidades diferentes y no define
nuestra inteligencia
creemos y hacemos creer que los jóvenes
no tienen la capacidad de aprender y de
destacar los frenamos y no les damos la
oportunidad de mostrarlo y se los
decimos en la cara
pues con todo esto me vienen dos
historias
hay talentos como bill ya ellis que a
sus 17 años ya era reconocida
mundialmente como una de las mejores
cantantes del mundo
en los grammys de jazz rogaba por no
ganar porque sabe que la atacarían
incluso se veía como le hacían zoom y
salía rogando y rogando que no quiere
ganar porque para muchos ella no tenía
la experiencia ella no merecía ese
reconocimiento por su corta edad
las palabras que usaban en contra de
ella eran tantas y tan negativas que
ella misma creía que no lo merecía
cuando sí
o por ejemplo la otra que se viene a la
mente es una chava de 26 años increíble
en su trabajo al que le costó mucho
llegar a donde está le tocó la
experiencia de ahora ser jefa donde ella
es la más joven
si sabes que el podrían ser el jefe o
sea el tienen como 39 y ella tendrá 5 no
ja ja
eso fue uno de los comentarios que
dijeron de ella por ser jefa porque no
entendían como una persona de su edad
podría tener un puesto así
y estas dos historias me llevaron a
entender algo muy importante
a tierra a tierra mucho saber que ya no
fuimos nosotros no sólo queremos que
nuestro tiempo de cumplir nuestros
sueños ha terminado sino que también
frenamos los años de los jóvenes
es que vemos a alguien de 57 años
queriendo aprender algo nuevo y nos
brincan
creemos que ya lo debe haber aprendido
todo pero a la vez vemos a un joven que
ya ha aprendido y que tiene muchas
capacidades y lo lo frenamos
porque creemos que no tiene la
experiencia
nos prohibimos
y dejará crecer
el tiempo y el aprendizaje son relativos
yo pensaba que no era una persona
inteligente
y que se me había acabado el tiempo
y lo confirmé una vez en una fiesta
donde viví una experiencia en donde
estábamos jugando un juego era un juego
de votar de señalarlo y decíamos ay
quién es la más bonita diseña la
vainilla quién es la más fiestera
y por mí votaron por la más tonta
usaron el poder de la palabra de una
forma tan negativa
que me lo cree
tuve todos los votos
me puse esa palabra decidí usarla
y creer que no haría nada relevante en
mi vida olvide todas mis capacidades
y cuando recordé esta historia
entendí que fui parte de ese 40%
el poder de la palabra que tenemos es
enorme
fui parte de ese porcentaje que eligió
una carrera por los amigos y no por sus
capacidades
pensaba que mi tiempo de poder hacer
algo importante había terminado incluso
todavía saben a lo que me dedico que
redes sociales condiciones y creen que
no es algo importante que es imposible
absurdo que hay algún tipo de
inteligencia ahí
esto hizo que yo sola me presionara y
caí en una crisis de ansiedad porque no
entendía que existían los tipos de
inteligencia tal vez lo había escuchado
pero no lo había entendido
y que cada uno es igual de importante e
increíble a su manera y no me
consideraba relevante pensar que no
tenga capacidades de hacer algo
increíble no sabía que lo que hacía
igual de importante que los demás
hasta que un día me llegó el mensaje de
una seguidora donde decía que gracias a
mí y gracias a la fundación de la que
soy parte su hermana no se suicidó
salvamos una vida
y ahí aprendí
yo quería cambiar al mundo sin entender
que ya lo estaba cambiando pensaba que
no era inteligente pero me di cuenta que
cada tipo de inteligencia y cada pequeña
acción y cada palabras son relevantes
para ti para mí y para el mundo que tal
vez yo siendo joven no sería el futuro
en ciencia pero si con mis palabras tal
vez no cambiaré al mundo pero cambiaría
el mundo de una persona
y ahora estoy aquí logrando lo contando
mi experiencia celebrando mi
inteligencia y la de los demás
porque todos venimos aquí a compartirlo
y cambiar el futuro juntos unos
enfocados en ciencia otros en emociones
otros en la vida
y tú en que te enfocas
como usas el poder de tu palabra
porque como albert einstein dijo todos
somos genios pero si juzgas a un pez por
no poder subir un árbol vivirá toda su
vida pensando que es un inútil
gracias